apenas un mes después de que la Unión
Europea aprobara sanciones al contra
Irán de nuevo adopta nuevas medidas en
una segunda ronda los cancilleres
europeos han aprobado la adopción de
medidas contra 29 individuos y tres
entidades sospechosos de haber
participado en la represión de las
protestas tras el asesinato de la joven
masa a mini Pero además los ministros
han aprobado también nuevas sanciones
contra dos empresas de drones y también
dos generales para haber participado y
ha ayudado en la invasión en Ucrania
además también se han adoptado medidas
contra el ministro de interior iraní
también la televisión Estatal press TV
así como la brigada que detuvo a la
joven masa a Mining En total son ya más
de 100 individuos los que se han
sancionado hasta ahora por parte de la
Unión Europea Pero estas medidas
aumentan la tensión entre Bruselas y
Teherán en un momento en que también se
la situación del pacto nuclear pese a
todo ha habido contra medidas por parte
del gobierno iraní una situación que de
hecho el jefe de la diplomacia europea
es josep borrella criticado y tacha de
error aún así en plenas negociaciones
Con el impacto nuclear con Irán Bruselas
insiste en que son asuntos completamente
distintos que no se deben mezclar y de
hecho Estados Unidos en la Unión Europea
siguen decididos a poder revitalizar
este acuerdo